先は長いなぁ
じゃあ和美社長です皆さんポケモンご存知でしょうか
聞か中華え流ヤドランピジョン公団
行った2バッドギャロップサンダースめのくらげ
パワーからたまたまから不思議ターネットたっくさんいるわけなんですけどそんな
たくさんいるポニー本の中でも皆さんたの知ってると思うんですけどもディザードンっ
ていうポケモン雑記
んですよポケモン提供な素敵なもので進化をするですリザードン桃とかない山のんだっ
たり山の方がいなくて彼はちゃんと段階を踏んで進化してデザートって言っている理由
ができます
歯と歯だこれよそよそしいどこまでなん朝としてね
よっしゃで畑仕事もとカメラ皆人だけって言うほど何でこの子
この子だったんですけども一つ下が進化してリザードウィザードが進化してディザード
ンっていう3回進化してんだポケモンテンダーなんかよくわかんないんだけども
1回嫉妬することもトミカへ進化するポケモンがいるんだけど
そこまでなんですよ動き方はなぜか2回しかしかできないんですそれなぜかわかりませ
んだメガシンカっていう特殊な進化はあるんですけどもちゃんと進化するポケモンて
基本的に3回までしかシーンがしないんですよここで話を本棚
俺も弱いぽいを使いたくねぇ思った夫強い pro 4で39目指すためにはに寝具
ちゃーん
もう無理もう被害欲しい方の話勝てないので visa
ドンのもしあのイメージでいいんであのリザードと進化したポケモンのイラストを考え
てくれませんかって発注しましたこれすなわちも普通のポケモン世界の膝動画も最終
形態なんですよそこがさらにもうもうイラストレーターさんの勝負で骨噛み砕いてアハ
年は絵が下手なので書きません
何でも本番の人もプロプロの人に d
じゃあの進化を支えてもらいましたそしてさーんそのビザの進化の進行別のイラスト
データさんで頼んでリザードの神が写真でしたそれの心境差別は皆さん回答でリーダー
どうもー進化の進化の進化の進化のシンガーの震源の鎮火させるとどんなポケモンに
なってるんだ今日は見て行きたいと思います皆様
気になると思うんですよデザートお菓子からどうぞ
の香り zard のせいかしたそれがさらにしがするとどうなるのかそれならさん4
月どうなるのか今日は外すと一緒に見ていきましょう
ポケモンゲットだぜ
フライブ天元見ていきましょう最終的には10系たいんですねちょっとがゲイリーさあ
のリザードその進化新刊進化深化はからではまずウィザードの神が見ていきましょう
第4形態といったところですねこちらでどうぞ
あ
なるほどねそうもうへちゃってる感じがしますね
はいはいああなるほどではないかあんまりぱっといまだディザードの人権残っている気
がしますねはい
あシフトどんどん要素次ぎ第五形態です
こっからどうなんですからね大口径でこちらですどうぞ
だいぶ原型がなかった汗だけが重い取るところを継承した感じがありますねやっぱり
元気
ないないけどなくから家でまたに zard と言われればディザードなるような気が
しますビザの大学系と言いますこちら
はいっ
[音楽]
ジャンポストどうした急に見てくれたしいやー米ネストデータさんにバトンを渡して
言ってるからなか卯
曲がすごい4月付けたこれはもうねーなんか戦闘力測ったらたらそうですけどまあまあ
リザーが僕ありますね
7度強くなりすぎた後終っちゃったテープですねはい通じて楕円なら携帯ですこちら
ですはい
[音楽]
フッって場合は曲がってるんでもうちょっと意外されたたまってくださいこれ方向性が
もうあの龍玉集めやってますけどもこれまでも気持ち分かりますから強くなればなる
ほどタブこういう方向性に酔っちゃうんでしょ
だいぶでも強そうですね細身のドラゴンカラーするとかなり変わったと思います
霧リザードです
思っちゃいますけどじゃあ続いて第8形態ですこちら入っ
[音楽]
おいこのや船だからなんかすごいバクーダとゴローン
マグラック止めとか山に言うでしょうねえっ
武康としてないこれだけ思考としてねこれらへオーカーできればブーブー
どんどんなく凶悪な感じになってきちゃいますねこれじゃああくって感じますよ
第9現在ですどうなるでしょうかレザーの子連れはい
嘘だろあって来なきゃいけないもーもーもーもーディザートじゃない皆様くださいこれ
リザードじゃないよあーー聞こえマッチ強さっているも駄目だよこんなことしたかね
どうしたの
お兄ねお兄ちゃんこれもこれは見てリザードンという人はおらんでしょ
さあ沿って最後で最終ケータイ代10形態ですこちらです
どうぞ
オープンはぞでも皆さんいろんな飛行船いろんな戦闘機は捕獲しようと思ってボール
投げてますねこれ
手前にいるのもポケモンじゃないですよこれはれ担架でタップですからもう選ぶと
データのに協力いただいて
リザードもう一つだけのことあると人影を9回進化させると
こちらのを基本になることがわかりましたありがとうございます
トップ
焦げこれで終わりじゃなくて実はゼニガメと不思議大バージョンを準備して頂きました
ちょっとこれを見ていきましょうか
ゼニガメの神が見ていきましょうかネックの進化ですこちら
おおーー
それっぽいそれっぽいそれっぽいそれっぽいですね後ろの日やがもしっかり増えて数え
て元気がちょっとカメックス感が出てていいか g の修行ですかいい感じできてます
よ
続いて第五形態ですこちらはい
[音楽]
プロパンなんでスカウターをつけたやついて第6型たいですこちらあー
わからんでもない方向性ですなるほどですねちょっともうメカメーカーチックになっ
ちゃったタイプですねこれ
スカウターをちゃんのゴーゴリに変形してますちょっとポケモン子ぶって場所が何か
良いですねさせメイラストデイゆたかんって感じですすごい
それで代なら携帯こちらですはい
お酢
母
嫌な予感がしてきたらこれガンダム方向に進まないことを入れますよ
いやーカッコイイですねあり映像本当に進化し続けるとこういう方向性なんだと思い
ます多分ダイハツ携帯ですこちらはいあー大
あっあーっ夏稀にポケモーイーサーそれっぽくするもうちょっとなんですかこれうまい
ロスコ
今7位から8つで俺だしてにかめくってよると渡部君ですねこれ
いやーこれかっこいいスバルと好きですよ山の本の新刊の2階です
九大旧境内こちら範囲
待って待って待って待って少したどうしたどうした第何兄弟って書いてると一緒なん
ですよさっきもあのリザードすごい方向性か入れましたけどもうどうして骨にさあ
すごいことによってきた打つ飛び乗ってしまったやばいキラー番だよこれが最終形態に
大丈夫携帯2ヶ月こちらですはいああああ待ってるなあこれ俺かありがとうございます
僕ですけどやばい穴で大和商科大ってコレカメックスのハイドロフォームでたいような
聞きしてますねこれ
ためいくとコネクト港南区露橋夏ですねうわぁ
野菜が不思議たりのシーンが見ていきましょうフシギバナの新刊こちらですはい
大
アジサシそうラフレシアが出ちゃった感じですね全然ありますいい感じです
第五形態こちらですはい
まくよえっつつスーパーもあるよまぁでもなんか楽でした的な方向性ではあって目移り
しますけどすごい競合性が増してきましたね
台の携帯小皿待って初めてフォアまでタッチ位置が逆停止取るパックフラウ方が大きく
なってきましただけどこれやでほっからの変化がもう逆に楽しくなってきたらもう女
だけんだこちら
うわ本体が入れ替わってるまであるめちゃくちゃ
花で返してフシギバナだった方が退化しているような気がしますけどからどうなるん
でしょうかダイハツ携帯こちらはい1て目が3つになっつってるよ
したも2つ出しでも周りのポケモンと同じンっているので ok です
毎回ここでガーンと雰囲気を変えていきます耐久携帯のフシギバナこちらですどっ
ダメダメだねひとたびてる人食べてるよヤバイよこれよだめだっはぁっ
うわあああああああああしこりやが方してますねすごいなってきてもうちょっと名
くれるの継承してるし
さあこっから最後で最初進化第二形態これ入っ
がで進化しすぎた不思議ばだわー
父の花より
あなた台の超育んだのであっ
ああああああ
[音楽]
ん
goo
[音楽]